we might assume that letting people know
what we want and how we feel is
relatively easy we surely just open our
mouths and say it but human life shows
extraordinary troubles around
communicating our intentions and
emotions clearly and honestly this is
some of what we get up to as an
alternative to straightforward
communication we say nothing but somehow
expect to be understood anyway and blame
the person for not reading our minds we
don't get something off our chest we go
in for people-pleasing behavior but
secretly we build up hatred and
resentment we pretend we don't care we
become avoidant and tough we say things
are okay and they're not okay at all we
explode dramatically rather than explain
calmly the explosion often being the
result of a past burial of the problem
that then gives way to an eruption of
resentment we nag bitterly we give up
even trying to explain and get
interested in trying to order impose and
control instead there's so much that we
should be talking about what we want in
bed how hurt we are by certain things
our friends and family do usually
inadvertently how badly we need a cuddle
but don't want to look weak by asking or
how we want to pay rise a promotion or a
shift to another role we feel sure we do
very well non communication starts early
it's almost always the result of a
certain sort of childhood in which we
were not allowed to get things off our
chests in a direct and sincere way
perhaps we had an angry parent around
whom we had to walk on eggshells we had
to be so careful with what we said or a
terrifying explosion could be unleashed
at any point maybe we had a prudish
parent it broke their heart every time
we were a bit rough or unhygenic no
wonder we now find it hard to be frank
about our body and its desires and needs
or maybe we had a very fragile parent
whom we loved but were always afraid of
bringing problems too in case they
couldn't take it and broke down or
perhaps the parent was too preoccupied
and busy our concerns with nothing next
to the challenges they had with the
corner shop the doctors surgery or the
business bad communication has its roots
in the feeling that you can't be both
truthful and
rated and loved who you are isn't enough
once we get more conscious of how
reluctant we are to communicate directly
we may be able to start to take action
by understanding our past we can see
that the present may not in fact require
the compromises around communication we
once had to accept as children without
quite noticing it we may be sticking
with a very unfortunate habit that was
formed understandably to deal with
problems that actually belong to another
past era we can afford to be bolder
we're stronger now and others are
stronger than we might imagine most
people can actually take some stiff news
and if they really can't we can walk
away put yourself in the shoes of those
you are afraid of is it really so nice
to be lied to you're not told what
matters people need to know the bad news
to fix it we can endure the risk of
being disliked in the name of a
cleansing confrontation we should go
through mental exercises to practice an
inner resilience around communication I
may be sacked but I can find another job
they may not like me here but there'll
be other places where I can find friends
what I feel is not always bad or strange
it deserves to be heard we have to tell
ourselves helpful important things that
we fail to hear from others sufficiently
loudly early on you're going to be okay
whatever happens next I will love you
even if the news is challenging enough
of stalking the earth with our shoulders
hunched and our eyes weary we have
nothing to be ashamed of we can afford
to say what we really feel to those who
deserve to hear it
you